trigonometric is a bit of a mouthful
right so we're very very often we just
abbreviate it to tree remember I said to
you this big idea underneath triangle
measurement geometry is that the sides
and the angles they relate to each other
just like the different measurements of
your body relate to each other right if
you have a certain size shoe that tells
you something about you know is this
length of your leg and the length of
your arms and so on okay so here the
idea is that these angles and the sides
are related okay now let me just give
you a quick picture of this okay look up
put your pens down I want you to imagine
here you go this is the triangle we've
drawn right now you got a right angle
here okay we called this theta okay now
at the moment I've got little a and
little B here now can you see if I keep
this triangle more or less the same but
if I change what happens to feed if I
make it bigger or smaller watch if I
make it really really small for instance
okay so so here's B down the bottom okay
if I make it really tiny something like
this say there's Peter now little Peter
okay can you see if theater is little
then a also has to be little right like
this angle makes this side right and
it's the same way for with the other
direction if I made feeder enormous
right if I made it okay here's he's my
same B right and I need to feed a really
tall like this see that's a that's a
bigger angle
okay well now be sorry
a rather he's got a really enormous
right so you can see a always kind of
has this relationship with the angle
right in fact both of the sides have
this relationship so to try and
understand what this relationship is we
introduced these three ratios which is
like what's the ratios when you compare
two different quantities think and the
ratios have fancy names and I'm going to
teach them to them okay the first ratio
is called sine
okay yeah please write them down okay
it's called sight right si n e not sin e
right sign it comes from a old word
another language it might be Arabic or
Indian
that means curve I'll explain why that
is in the future okay but just for now
sign now we tend to abbreviate that too
without the e okay
but we still pronounce it side right it
still comes from here so that's why this
is not sin it's science
all right now there's another ratio okay
it's called a cosign okay
cosign there by the way sign I told you
it means curve has to do with a
particular ratio the car in cosine you
can see them obviously related right the
curse dance for compliment not as in you
remember we talked about compliments
like hey nice haircut and compliments in
geometry with an e which means what is
it when two angles are complements they
add up to their supplements when they
are 208 and their complements when they
add up to 90 okay we will come back to
this idea again I just want you to sort
of flag it and have a reason so this is
the second ratio that's right and I'll
tell you what their issues are lastly
sorry cosine we abbreviate that to cause
okay three that is so ratio number one
review number two the third ratio is
called tangents just like with circles
tangent is this line yeah when you've
got a circle and there's a line which
just touches it right let's attach it so
we abbreviate that to ten okay yes okay
now here's the thing right
it's the ratio of particular size I'm
going to up there in a second
in relation to and angle okay so this is
my original triangle that we all drew at
the start right so you can say look I
would sign off an angle over there you
would read it that like this sine theta
okay or cos theta or ten feet up right
so you give it an angle and here's the
ratio you get for each one there's three
different ratios okay sine theta is you
look at this opposite side and the
hypotenuse you take you divide one by
the other opposite divided by hypotenuse
and that's a ratio right I comparing how
big is the opposite side in relation to
the highwayman okay wait cosine is
another ratio at this time said opposite
hypotenuse
it's j6 oops that's a dude turn into a J
adjacent on hypotenuse okay the last one
is tan right which is opposite adjacent
okay now you're like wow that's not a
lot to remember it is I'll teach you a
nice easy way to remember it in a second
so one last thing I want to point out
which is that I'm gonna rub off this
triangle how look at ten turns a bit
different to the others
actually it's different in a lot of ways
and I'm going to unpack that over the
next couple weeks but the first way that
I'm going to show you is that CL sign is
a ratio of two sides and cons is a ratio
of two sides
you're like tens also a ratio of two
sides ah but it's a ratio something else
as well can you see right think this
through with me I know the fractions are
a tricky it's sign on
can you see this look at it with me if I
divided side theta by cos theta this
fraction by this fraction can you see
the hypotenuse is would cancel right let
me write it out for you
opposite on hypotenuse if I divide that
by adjacent okay how do you divide
fractions you multiply and then you flip
multiply then you flip so I'm gonna get
I'm gonna start abbreviating this
because they're very well multiply and
then flip like this okay but look cancel
cancel opposite on adjacent which is
what we called the tangent theta so this
here these are the three kinematic
ratios and we're going to unpack what
what you can do with these things is
really cool actually
now like I said it looks like a bit of a
mess to remember okay so I'm going to
teach you a mnemonic which is um it's
like a little memory device it's an
acronym it goes like this
saw so what you might have seen it
before what it stands for sohcahtoa is
on each of the ratios okay so sign
starts with an S so I inside is opposite
on hypotenuse right so that's the sort
of sohcahtoa okay
cosine starts at the C is adjacent on
hypotenuse or Sokka and tan is opposite
on adjacent okay so saw katoa right
there like that's the made-up word is
not real that's true but it's quite easy
to say and it's quite easy to remember